я от щось не можу зрозуміти А чому майже
за рік і дев'ять місяців від
повномасштабного Московського вторгнення
Верховна Рада таки не може винести в
залу і проголосувати законопроекти які
забороняють Московську церкву може
колеги нарешті зроблять пані Юлі вітання
на день народження і нарешті ми сьогодні
їх розглянемо У сесійній залі і
заборонимо цю
фсбшну катівську структуру якою є
Московська церква яка не має нічого
спіль ані з совістю ані з Вірою Ані зі
свободою ані з честю Мені би хотілось
нагазати цифри які сьогодні оприлюднила
Служба безпеки України 68 затриманих
попів і митрополитів Московської церквою
вони всі займалися не тільки державною
зрадою але вони займалися торгівлею
зброєю і дитячою порнографією колеги в
залі ви підтримуєте торгівлю зброєю і
розповсюдження дитячої порнографії то
чому в нас немає зараз на На порядку
денному законопроектів про заборону
ліквідацію Московської церкви і
розірвання будь-яких контактів з Москвою
московські попи наводили ракети на наші
міста і села московські попи роздають
зброю в церквах московським терористам
московські попупи До сих пір
відмовляються відспівувати наших
загиблих захисників питання ви це все
підтримуєте ви це все толеруєте вам це
все підходить якщо ні то я прошу будь
ласка підпишіться терміново під
скликанням позачергової сесії під
винесенням в залу законопроектів які
ліквідовують Московську церкву у нас є
законопроект
8221 який забороняє Московську церкву на
основі усіх можливих конвенцій з прав
людини посилаючись на питання
національної безпеки і це дасть нам
можливість заборонити добре винесіть в
залу ті інші урядові беззубі проекти
силовики просять служба безпеки просить
А Верховна Рада телиться захищаючи
московських церковних убивць Я хотіла би
нагадати монобільшості що сьогодні не
голосуючи не виносячи в сесійну залу
законопроекти про заборону Московської
церкви ви підставляєте президента
Зеленського бо Саме тут з цієї трибуни
на День Конституції він заявив що ми
маємо позбутися духовної залежності від
Московської церкви то ви так зневажаєте
свого лідера Володимира Зеленського Чи
вам так на чхати чи можливо вам хтось
якісь вказівки дає з офіса президента
якщо ні то уже сьогодні законопроєкти
про заборону Московської церкви мають
бути тут В сесійній залі проголосовані і
найближчим ці часом прийняті за основу і
в цілому бо інакше Як казав Василь
Симоненко всі хто захищає Московську
церкву це байстрюки котів осатанілих бо
тільки такі люди можуть захищати Путіна
і його фсбешну структуру